greetings people of the world for years
you've been under the assumption that my
uncle Inspector Gadget was a respected
detective for the Metro City police
force this was all just a cunning ruse
did you really think such a bumbling
dick with the voice of Don Adams could
accomplish super impossible feats and
still be human for God's sake he is a
fucking helicopter in his head and yet
nobody questions where the hell is brain
is I created the gadget 9000 prototypes
and you dumb asses fell for it and now
that I've created artificial life I
shall unleash it on an unsuspecting
world your tanks and stealth bombers are
no match for the Hellfire I'm about to
unleash do you know how difficult was to
constantly be in the shadows is that
incompetent shit got all the credit I
compress the entire internet into my
textbook Todd k9 how to simulate human
speech and created the Apple watch
before Steve Jobs was out of his
mother's basement give me another 10
years I would have created a fucking
matrix complete with the Keanu Reeves
that can actually act you thought the
real enemy was mad but they were merely
a distraction as long as gadget and claw
thought the police were always occupied
for you see I was foiling mads plan so
that when the time came I seized control
of your governments your thermal nuclear
warheads your lives
I am penny mother of gadgets breaker of
brains I will take back the honor that
was stolen from me and destroy those who
stand in my way isn't that right uncle
gadget
whoa
any for your thoughts bitches
does that work yeah but you were
supposed to just say oh I don't like
that uncle gadget
you